أب حزين يضيء مصباح زيت
أمام صورة ابنه جاغديش
مكوان الله رأى ابنه في 30 أكتوبر
عندما قام جيريش ابن عمه وعمه البالغ من العمر عشر سنوات
برحلة بالدراجة إلى
المكان السياحي الشهير بالمدينة الجسر المعلق
في موربي غرب الهند
كانوا متحمسين للغاية عندما غادروا
المنزل ووعدوا بالعودة
بعد ساعات قليلة من قطع كابل الجسر.تم
انتشال جثثهم من
النهر
منذ أن زار أقارب
وجيران ماكوانا منزلهم
لتقديم تعازيهم
لكن الكلمات لم تهدأ.  هذه
الأم التي فقدت طفلها الأصغر
مشهد مألوف حول Morby أكثر من
عشرة أشخاص يحضرون يوم حداد
في المنزل الحدودي فقدوا 12 من
أحبائهم الذين تجمعوا من جميع أنحاء
الولاية للاحتفال بعيد ديوالي الهندوسي
أيام الأضواء
في وقت لاحق ، سقط خمسة أحفاد وأربع
بنات وثلاثة من أصهارهم حتى
الموت أثناء سيرهم على الجسر
[موسيقى
] فاجأوا الإجابة على بن وزوجها
و sundarji bodha في صمت
كان هناك الكثير من الوفيات لا أستطيع
وصف الألم والحزن
لأن أحفادهم كانوا يلعبون في هذه
الممرات الآن ، لا يوجد سوى غرف فارغة
وذكريات
استخدموها لخلق جو من الفرح
لجميع أفراد الأسرة كلما كانوا
من الصعب حتى التفكير في
أنهم لم يعودوا معنا
[موسيقى]
كانت أيامًا تفصلهم عن العودة إلى
المدرسة
كانوا قد انطلقوا إلى الجسر مع تسعة
أفراد آخرين من العائلة ولكن نجا ثلاثة فقط
من جدتهم ، وهو لا
بين أحدهم
كنا قد وصلنا إلى منتصف الجسر
عندما انهار ، كنت معهم ، وحصلت على
مساعدة من الناس ، وأنقذت
حياتي ، لكن زوجة ابنتي والأطفال
جميعًا
ماتوا ، ويؤلم هذه العائلة أن تجلس بجانب
متعلقاتهم لتذكير دائم  الحزن
والخسارة ،
تم تجديد جسر الحقبة الاستعمارية
قبل أيام فقط من إعادة
فتحه للجمهور ، وسرعان ما تحول إلى فخ موت
لبعض جيل كامل قضى على
منازلهم في المغرب و  ما وراء
الظلام غير المكتمل
CNN نيودلهي
الأجنبية